Thank You Ian and what a privilege it is
to be with this congregate
this sacred sacred day in the Christian
year when I was a little girl the
biggest thing that happened every year
in my hometown of Wilmington North
Carolina was the Azalea festival will
meet n is a town on the southeastern
coast of North Carolina that is
ordinarily known for local by locals for
two things the battleship North Carolina
that is docked there and flowers Guns
and Roses perhaps well in this case guns
and azaleas I grew up taking the beauty
of the city for granted I didn't realize
how wonderful it was to live in a city
where something bloomed all year long in
the winter it was the camellias deep
pink and white and variegated varieties
that my father loved to cut cut and
float in vases all through our house or
to send home without a town guests
nestled in a bed of Spanish moss and in
the spring of the year the whole city
came ablaze with dogwoods and azaleas so
to celebrate its beauty every year
Wilmington still has an azalea festival
which for children at least culminated
on Saturday morning with the Azalea
festival parade I still remember going
to my first parade when I was nine years
old and we had just moved to Wilmington
it was complete with marching bands and
baton twirlers and floats with
beautifully decked out people on them
and the parade would weave its way
through downtown Wilmington while crowds
lined the streets someone had given me
an autograph book as a gift that year
this was a little blank book in which i
think i was supposed to collect all the
signatures of all the famous people i
would meet in my life so i stood at that
parade side and every time a float would
stop in front of our family i would run
up lift my autograph book up high and
have someone on that float sign it the
prize autograph though was that of the
Azalea queen every year some second-tier
TV or
star or movie star came to our home town
and was wined and dined for a weekend
and got to be queen of our parade when I
was nine years old the Queen was Shelley
Fabares now I don't expect many of you
here have a clue who she was she starred
in the Donna Reed show which was a
popular show in the 50s of my childhood
oh do I still remember reaching my
autograph book up and getting Shelley
Fabares to sign it somehow when I
picture the first Palm Sunday parade I
picture it being sort of like my
hometown I say a festival parade Jesus
the celebrity is coming to town and it's
a big deal for all the crowds that have
gathered in the city for the annual
feast of the Passover throngs of adults
and children lined the streets that go
through the Kidron Valley up the winding
road to the walled city of Jerusalem
there on the hill the temple gleams in
the sunlight and the excitement is
palpable as street vendors sell their
wares and children ask their parents to
put them on their shoulders so they can
get a better glimpse now four hours are
in short supply in this arid land so
people cut branches off of palm trees or
bring sheaves of wheat and wave them
wildly as they wait for Jesus to arrive
and when he finally gets there the
crowds cheer Imam with gusto Hosanna
Hosanna blessed is the one who comes in
the name of the Lord they sing psalms
like they sang for the Great King David
when he would ride that path up to
Jerusalem and they hailed Jesus as the
long awaited King of the Jews yet the
funny thing is if you look closely
things are not as they should be in this
parade in fact it's pretty much a parody
of what it should be or narrowly a king
would ride into town on a big stallion
showing his power and his might and
Jesus chooses to ride in on a little
Colt that has not even been broken for
riding or narrowly a king
right into Jerusalem and full military
regalia flanked by weapons of war
showing forth the military strength
showing the will to overthrow the Romans
but Jesus comes in a non-violent and
peaceable way ordinary a king would ride
into the city with politics foremost on
his mind graciously thanking the crowds
for their welcome commenting pleasantly
on the beauty of their city in its
temple promising to up build both during
their brain and what does Jesus do one
of his very first acts after getting to
town is to go to the temple in a holy
rage overturn the money changers there
who were buying and selling sacrificial
animals and declare is it not written
that my house shall be a house of prayer
for all nations and you have turned it
into a den of robbers woof when I tried
to imagine this parade in a contemporary
scene I picture King Jesus riding into
my hometown of Wilmington not on a float
of flowers but maybe on a moped he might
even be wearing a clown suit with a
painted tier on one cheek when the
parade ends the crowd waits expectantly
for Jesus to go to the podium said it's
up at the end of the parade where all
the dignitaries are to thank them for
hosting him and instead he strides down
market street and into one of the old
historic churches there and starts
turning over the tables that advertise
the church night suppers and the
basketball tournaments he reminds the
political leaders of my hometown that
though the city is beautiful on the
outside the beauty hides some
deep-seated ugliness of racial
discrimination and Prejudice he reminds
them that in 1898 when the white
Aristarchus aristocracy of Wilmington
were upstaged in an election they
conspire
to run the duly elected black majority
out of town and the Cape Fear River
literally ran red with the blood of the
black leaders massacred he reminds the
church leaders and the good church folk
that they were complicit errs in this
discrimination and violence and that
they have refused to work for the things
that make for peace now don't get me
wrong I don't mean to pick on my home
town today I simply know its history
better than I know that of other cities
my guess is if Jesus came to New Haven
he would find equally offensive deeds
and acts to be angry about after all is
it this the place where the Divinity
School where I teach was built on land
purchased with remington gun money the
city where this very university sits on
land once formed by the Quinnipiac
Indians the town where in 1831 the
citizens voted by a majority of 700 24
to reject a proposal that the first
african-american college in the nation
be established here now I don't single
out Wilmington because it's more to
blame I only make the analogy so we can
imagine how furious the religious
leaders must have been with Jesus and
why Jesus does not play the role of
gracious accepting guests Jesus does not
play the role of hoped for King Jesus
does not play the role of honored
religious dignitary preaching a good
sermon and blessing everybody for coming
out to hear him instead through this
parody of a parade Jesus up ends all
illusions that the good folk have that
they are indeed good he confronts them
with their failure to live up to the
truths of God to God's will for
righteousness and justice and equality
and
life is it any wonder they despised him
is it any wonder that by weeks in the
crowd had changed from Hosanna to
crucify him get him out of this town two
colleagues of mine in the field of
preaching chuck campbell and johann
seniors have recently written a book
with the provocative title that I also
chose for my sermon today Jesus The Fool
in it they maintained that what was
going on that first palm sunday was
Street Theatre in which Jesus through
his intentional parody of the powers and
principalities of this world was
speaking out against the ways that were
against God Jesus they say is no passive
victim in Mark's Gospel silently going
toward the cross Jesus is acting out
Jesus is acting out in nonviolent
protest jesus literally plays the fool
in order to disrupt the current social
order and to convince folk that there is
a more profound truth the truth of God
if this is so then the question for us
becomes do we dare join Jesus in his
foolish parade do we dare join him in
his nonviolent resistance of the
principalities and powers of our day
well we dare become ourselves as the
Apostle Paul put it fools for Christ's
sake I would suggest to you that if we
looked out the windows over here today
out on chapel street and watch the
parade as Jesus leads it through town we
would see some other followers who have
chosen to be fools in that parade I
think I see Archbishop Desmond Tutu up
front there
you know the one who persistently
non-violently opposed with his whole
being apartheid in South Africa and who
one day in a pretty lampooning kind of
manner announced to the prime minister
of south africa and the heyday apartheid
mr. prime minister we must remind you
that you are just a man you are not God
and one day your name shall merely be a
faint scribble on the pages of history
while the name of jesus christ the lord
of the church will live forever and back
there I think I see William Sloane
coffin who used to preach right here in
this Chapel foolishly burning the draft
cards of vietnam war resisters and with
his ever humorous turn a phrase saying
to us you know we are beginning to
resemble extinct dinosaurs who suffered
from too much armor and too little brain
and look over there I think I see some
members of middle Collegiate Church in
New York City who last week all wear
more hoodies to church as a part of
their nonviolent protest against the
killing of Trayvon Martin and so many
youth like him and there you just might
see some folk from occupy wall street
movement right across the street joining
in line foolishly trying to overturn the
money tables with Jesus and saying
corruption and government has got to go
there are people in our land who are
suffering suffering because of the
inequality of wealth you see the truth
of the matter is I don't think Jesus
wants to write his name in our autograph
books today I think Jesus wants to write
his name on our hearts and in our lives
I think Jesus wants to recruit some more
people who were willing to dare to be
fools for his sake
so today he invites us first to come to
this table where the ultimate
foolishness of God in Christ is revealed
to us as our King is sacrificed on a
cross out of love for us to take his
body and blood into our bodies and our
blood and then to go out in this world
to be fools for him the parade is
passing by do we dare join its ranks